take your fitness to the next level with
the tune fit for s the pulse tracking
wristband that gets you in shape on and
off the field tune fit for s measures
distance traveled steps and floors
climbed all at the flick of your wrist
so you can chart your progress all day
with a variety of useful stats tune fit
for s automatically monitors your sleep
to show you how well you've slept and
for how long and if you're sleeping with
anybody how's that going use social mode
to connect with our tune and fit
community look out in shape and
attractive they are and now you can
share your workout results with the rest
of the world feeling stressed breath
tracker analyzes and corrects your
breathing patterns pulse and sexual
frustrations breathe you'll also stay
motivated with tuner penalty which keeps
you in check if you fail to meet your
goals if you miss runs consume bad
calories or continue being single you'll
lose points
because unhealthy eating and lifestyle
decisions not only kill you they keep
you alone forever we believe the path to
a better life is right in front of you
it's really not that hard at all Kate
stop running from your problems and
start running toward your solutions Kate
make every breath count because breath
is limited and you only have so many
before you die and you don't want to die
alone right
are you still singing what happened to
all your goals other day to go
to fit for s we're talking to you Kate
[Music]
ah